we are learning more now about the
omicron variant from scientists in south
africa where it was first reported an
early study there found omicron is at
least 2.4 times more likely to reinfect
someone who had coveted before compared
to other variants the strain is also
highlighting inequalities in the global
covid response deborah patta is in
johannesburg debra good morning
good morning in the turf war between
omicron and delta the new variants was
clearly winning accounting for a
meteoric rise in new infections in south
africa and it's inserted itself firmly
into the global debate on vaccine
inequality
it's been the war cry of health experts
around the globe since the pandemic
began nobody is safe until everyone is
safe had we done the scientific thing
had we done what the scientists were
saying in january february 2020 we would
not be now where we are
and what science tells us says a furious
dr ayawade al-aquija is that unless
there is global vaccine equity the virus
will continue to mutate
in the two countries where omicron was
first identified botswana has already
administered 86 percent of its supply
south africa 78
compare this to wealthy nations where
it's predicted 100 million expired
vaccines could be destroyed at the end
of the year this is because they've
hoarded them says alikija
we're saying get out of the queue so
that we can get to the front of the line
and get our own and pay for them
complicating matters further is
distribution many african countries lack
the logistical capability to get shots
into people's arms and travel bans only
further isolate this region
californian monika glass was visiting
her husband's family in south africa
when her flights were cancelled southern
africa is the only place who
they instilled these travel bans
right and i just
i feel like it's unfair it's not right
then another blow while waiting to make
new travel arrangements she tested
positive for covert
and is isolating in cape town
i
i have mild symptoms i am vaccinated
and i'm a nurse so i work in a coveted
unit
i've been around covid
and this is the first that i've had
covet as far as i'm aware
a far bigger concern is getting home to
her three children when the infection
clears
travel bans are causing further chaos
with south african scientists saying
there are fewer planes coming in that
can bring the necessary compounds to
study omicron sparking fears they could
run out
deborah patta and johannesburg thank you
very much